She's one of the dumbest
you've ever seen in your life. Like, it's one of the two. There's
no way you can get that much wrong where like, yeah, she was
accusing Trip of being a doctor. She accused me of grooming somebody
because apparently she just can't do maths at all. Um, she literally
posts like
uh she went and got my
my criminal records, posts them, docses me like post my records
and uh with like my full name and everything and then types out
completely
different that is not on the on the record like that is not my
record. That is not what I got arrested for. She types out something
totally different
on her paper than what was
than what was in the record. Like it's just drastically drastically
different. And then
she What what was the other thing? She uh Oh, yeah. And then
she also said that I like I said I got arrested for this. I said
that I got I went to prison for racketeering. I said no like
no evidence of this. nothing showing this anywhere. Nothing nothing
uh proving this and like showing where I ever said this cuz it
just never happened. It didn't it didn't happen. Didn't get said.
Um
and so yeah.
And so yeah, I was a heroin addict for a long time. Uh from like
the age 15 to about 19. Um and I was a con man. I was a drug
dealer
and I would like rob houses. I would rob drug dealers. I would
um I was selling drugs and so initially I got arrested arrested
did six months in county
um for burglary, residential burglary. I had robbed probably
like hundreds of houses but I got arrested for three.
Then after I did the six months, I got 10 years probation, got
out, and then two weeks later got arrested on racketeering charges
and debit card theft and debit card fraud charges. >> I'm
so sorry to interrupt you for a >> Thank you so much Burns
for the raid. I really much appreciate it. Hi everybody. Right
now we're talking >> to Tom Foolery show. >> Yes,
we're >> first offender. You get a lesser charge type thing.
you get a lesser charge, it gets taken off your record. Um, like
a at most, I think they'll put you on like a year probation.
Um, and then, yeah, as long as you finish that, like you you
walk away like you never committed a crime. But if you do
reaffend while on probation, you you get the book, like you get
hammered. And so I was back there after offending on first offenders.
And so they're like, >> "Yeah, they don't." It was very
very I I was on 10-year probation or sorry, no, no, no, sorry,
it's not a year at most. I was on 10-year probation under first
offenders and then offended my 10-year probation in two weeks.
I had just done 6 months, got out. Two weeks later, I was back
for an even worse charge. This time they So, initially, they
arrested me for racketeering.
So, prison was for drugs because I've never heard you talk about
it >> kind of. So, I went to um I got arrested once for
residential burglary and that was because I was actually like
stealing stuff to get drug money.
And then
um and then I got arrested
uh credit card theft and credit card fraud
and
um
and it was like one count of each and then uh racketeering.
>> You went to prison how long?
>> Uh that one was 13 and a half months. Um I got extended
because they said that I attacked the cops. So I was up I was
locked up for 6 months uh in county, got out for 2 weeks and
then went away for 13 months. Um and that time I went to state
but
um originally they arrested me for racketeering and they convicted
me of like 15 other charges instead. So,
um, >> but yeah, anyways, so my girlfriend's dad was friends
with the,
um, with the county sheriff, and the sheriff was the head of
the Georgia drug task force. And so he was the one who had all
these connections and was helping an investigation on me for
racketeering and
um,
all of that crap. So yeah.
What's about to happen, dude? Are they about to shoot us or about
they about to arrest us or are they just like scoping us out?
What's going on? And and then they just pull off and drive off
and Yep. Eventually they came
they uh they arrested me and they the idea was that I was um
I was getting charged with racketeering. I never got at like
convicted of racketeering but they ended up while they were doing
that investigation
charged me with
I I think 15 other counts of other crimes. And so that's what
I'm talking about when I show Sassifras my rap sheet and it's
got a whole bunch of stuff. That's what they were doing the entire
time. They arrested me wanting to get me on racketeering and
then they charged me with a ton of other things.
She what what was the other thing she uh Oh yeah. And then she
also said that I like I said I got arrested for this. I said
that I got I went to prison for racketeering. I said no like
no evidence of this. nothing showing this anywhere. Nothing nothing
uh proving this and like showing where I ever said this cuz it
just never happened. It didn't it didn't happen. Didn't get said.
Um
and so yeah, like she just she was just full on skitso. And this
is a like 40 chapter thing, like 500 pages, something that like
she bragged about like working on it day and night for two months.
Like this is she was just completely skits, dude. Completely
nuts. Just totally nuts.
Um,
and it was Yeah, it was a